[Music]
on halloween night
wilson sort of shadow
maybe all this
[Music]
is happening for a reason
these are not nightmares
it's happening you shouldn't go now
it's almost here
[Music]
you still have that mat that what that
one with the nails
hey everybody happy friday the 13th you
still got that bat the one with all the
nails in it
grab it now so let's break this down
stranger things is coming back
in two weeks that's right it'll drop
thursday at midnight
in two weeks for me posting this trailer
so just depending on how fast people are
able to get through it i'll do easter
egg videos so be sure to subscribe to
get everything i'll probably do some
giveaways as part of that too
but the whole thing here is that you
just see them gearing up for
war with the monsters from the upside
down in a way they didn't last season
last season was all about proving that
there was something weird going on
and then finding out the conspiracy
behind the hawkins laboratory
now that they know that it's real will
even says in the trailer you should run
now he's almost here as in the thessale
hydra which is just what i'm calling
this for now they'll probably have a
slightly different name for it
but because the game always informs some
of the action of the series like they
played the game at the beginning of
season 1 they called it the demogorgon
and then when they found the real
monster they just
called that the demogorgon i think
they'll be the same thing with the
thessale hydra
but it's going to be much much worse
last season it was just one monster i
think it's going to start spreading all
over the place and it all starts around
halloween which is why they're dropping
the series around halloween
you probably pick up on this too you see
a lot of the teenagers plot
intersecting with the kids plot whereas
last season there was more of a clear
division between their two storylines so
you had all the stuff that was happening
with the teenagers
then you had the kids running around
with 11 and by the end of the series
then they sort of collided the adults
with the kids the upside down in the
return of will
so the difference now is that you just
see teenagers like steve
running around with the kids all season
long instead of just waiting to the end
to bring all those story lines together
but there still are a couple different
story lines so whereas you have
teenagers with the kids
you also notice that there's no 11
running around with them either
she's off by herself like they cut some
different footage in this so you know
that she
escapes from the same place where she
defeated the demogorgon in the upside
down so she's literally just like pushes
through realities
back into the school and then escapes so
she goes to her dropbox to grab the
precious precious eggos that hopper's
been leaving for her there
and then you see her show up at terry
ive's house if you don't remember
that's her mother so she goes back to
her mother's house and it looks like she
is
pissed off she has that new wig on and
then
separately you see her using her power
she seems like she's gotten a little bit
more powerful too i think that's the
idea is that she matures she gets used
to her abilities
she becomes more proficient so the thing
is is that even though right now she's
supposed to be the most op
character on the show they did say that
some of the other new characters would
be instrumental in stopping the thessale
hydra
so one of those is the new mad max
character this ginger here that's
running around with steve's baseball bat
so she's just like a tomboy that falls
in with the group she's sort of like an
outsider
but then you also have the roman
character who's coming back
because it sounds like she used to be
one of the other test subjects too
remember 11 is number 11 so there are 10
other kids
so it sounds like part of her storyline
will have her off by herself for a
little while before she reunites with
the group but i think we all expect that
too so you have the kids
with will dealing with the emergence of
these visions that he's having like he
keeps seeing the thessale hydra they
start freaking out they're not sure
what's going on
but we learned that he opened a portal
to the upside down
right at the end of the season so it's
just evidence that places like the
pumpkin patch here will start
turning into the upside down that was
actually one of the working titles of
the episodes
and they actually have confirmed a
couple of the episode titles but not
every single one
you get some more shots of hopper we're
gonna learn a little bit more about his
backstory remember he came to this town
to become the sheriff because he wanted
to get away from his old life he
divorced his wife after their child
died so that's why he sort of
emotionally adopted eleven so he's
probably gonna be more happy than
anybody else that she's back
but this conspiracy room here might
actually be
barb's father's house they did say that
barb's father would be a new character
during this season
and they'd have some way of invoking
justice for barb i never quite
understood why she was such a big
character i think she was more popular
with younger audiences
and it just started to trend and become
this big thing justice for barb
so they said they weren't bringing that
character back but they would find a way
to
get justice for barb and that sounds
like what's going on here her father
starts tracking the mystery of her
disappearance
and he and the other members of the
community just start to prepare for all
[ __ ] to break loose
that really is one of the biggest
differences between last season and this
season
is that regular people are getting ready
for crazy stuff to happen
not just the little kids but everybody
let me know in the comments what do you
think of this so far
i'm sure there's going to be crazy 80s
easter eggs usually it's a lot of steven
spielberg 80s horror flicks
but like i said this is dropping in two
weeks so i'll probably post my first
episode video on friday and then after
that we'll just see how long it takes
everybody to get through the episodes
and i'll just post based on that
but what'll happen next is there'll be
some new rick and morty i have some game
of thrones to post this weekend
in my dc tv flash arrow q a video
so just look out for all that stuff if
you have any special requests just leave
them in the comments below you can click
here to re-watch that new mutants
trailer and you can click here to watch
the last big stranger things trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight
you